we're all gonna have to get used to
wearing a face mask from flights abroad
to your local supermarket masks or face
coverings are now in a central bit of
kit in England so why the sudden change
because the Funday make it snug yet over
[Music]
well the evidence has been growing that
people can transmit kovat 19 even when
they don't show symptoms they might feel
well but they can still breathe out the
virus so it makes sense to do whatever
you can to reduce the number of virus
particles potentially reaching other
people social distancing at least one
meter ideally two is by far the best way
of doing that but the World Health
Organization the Royal Society and lots
of other scientific bodies now agree
that when that's not possible
and you're in an enclosed space a Faced
covering can reduce the chances of the
virus spreading by how much it's
impossible to give you one easy number
there are big differences between
studies but to give you an idea a study
in The Lancet medical journal found the
risk of passing on the virus when
wearing a mask was 3 percent compared to
17 percent we're not wearing one what
about different types of masks well
without doubt the most effective is the
respirator mask they're close fitting
with a good filter and they reduce the
risk of being infected as well as
passing on the infection but they're in
short supply and medical bodies want
them reserved for frontline health
workers next up is the surgical masks
there's not yet much evidence that they
protect the wearer but if they're
infected it does catch some of the virus
in their breath reducing the risk to
other people nearby but again supplies
are meant for health workers face
coverings of what the general public are
being asked to use they're made of
fabric usually cotton and that traps the
virus and the tighter the weave of the
material and the greater the number of
layers the better and it's ideally going
to have a wire on the bridge here to
make a clothes fit around your nose but
this is the really important bit master
should never be shared they should be
washed after every use ideally it's 60
degrees
before putting them on or take them off
you should wash your hands or use
and even with a mask social distancing
is still just as important
all this will take some getting used to
MRSA been widely used in Asia for many
years but in some European countries
they've quickly become a common sight as
the virus has spread in Spain and Italy
more than four in five people now wear
them in the UK it's just a third but
this will soon be the new norm
[Music]